the super bowl is less than two weeks
away and this year it's gonna look
different
now not just in the stands um which will
be at one third capacity
but from your couch too ap reports that
budweiser pepsi
and coke are slashing their super bowl
ads this year pepsi is going to focus on
the halftime show
but this one really caught me anhyzer
bush is going to air
ads for other products but they're going
to skip budweiser
which is such a you know statement piece
in the super bowl ads
because they're taking that money to
donate it towards a vaccine program
yeah that's amazing incredible so no
clydesdales this year
but we get coveted vaccines instead i'll
take that switch
absolutely yeah right i mean you have to
applaud these companies who spend
millions and millions and millions of
dollars really focusing on what's
important
i applaud that yeah um i also will miss
some of the commercials i just have to
say
because i re i don't remember who won
the game in like 1993 but i remember
like ali landry caught a dorito in her
mouth
okay so i got another one for you
because i know you're um in the dating
scene
and um okay i just want to like
steer you in the right direction because
please if you have any tips it is
fraught with peril okay
blind dates my husband and i were a
blind date so do not say no to the
friends who want to set you up on a
blind date
you've had a beautiful successor 33
years
so it's all good so here's the story
that we saw in the new york post this
lady
caught her date scrolling through a
dating app while they were out to dinner
now she took a picture of him on her
cell phone while he was doing this
he was pretending that he was looking at
the menu because now you do the qr code
and the menus on your phone so you don't
have to touch it
oh i'm just checking out the other
options it wasn't mozzarella sticks or
jalapeno peppers
he's looking at other chicks on bumble
needless to say
there was no second date can you imagine
she
caught him red-handed okay seriously
drew i have to wonder if you were on a
date and you caught somebody doing this
what would you do because i know what i
would do
i did go on a date where uh the first
one of the first things they said was i
have to
be somewhere after this and i was like
wow that is certainly an
entry point and then it wasn't really
going well and i was like don't you have
to
get to that thing what i thought was
like insulting to start out with is now
my
exit strategy so it might be a good
thing
i used to have people page me when i was
doing a blind date i would have them
page me and you know i'm a reporter so
if it was
um a good date i would just say oh
update on a story excuse the
interruption if it was an awful day
i've got to meet the crew if i don't
five months of undercover work is going
to go
well if i was on a date and i saw
somebody swiping i know exactly what i
would do
what i would order the most expensive
thing on the menu lobster for me i'd eat
it and then i go powder my nose and
deuces
with you guys all day long every day all
day long